durant des années la reine de la
provocation s'appelait madonna jamais à
l'abri d'un dérapage pour faire parler
d'elle aujourd'hui la star de la chanson
semble avoir trouvé plus sulfureuse
qu'elle avec la chanteuse américaine
rihanna il ya moins de dix ans et dans
un clip sulfureux intitulé porter que la
jeune artiste qui a aujourd'hui 32 ans
avait choqué de nombreux américains
plus récemment c'est l'utilisation de
paroles du prophète mahomet remixé sur
de la musique électro lors d'un défilé
de lingerie de la star qui avait fait
grand bruit
[Applaudissements]
et aujourd'hui toujours pour faire la
promotion de sa marque de lingerie savic
x 106 que l'artiste a posté une photo
d'elle
et sa nuque hachée par ses bras un
cliché sur lequel rihanna porte des
accessoires à l'image du dieu hindou
ganesh de son côté le conseil mondial
hindoue a affirmé avoir déposé plainte
pour obtenir leurs traits d'image alors
rihanna accusée de blasphème comprenez
vous la polémique
[Musique]
je me permets de dire oui et non ça fait
plein de fois votre récap l'a bien
montré et à chaque fois c'est volontaire
elle fait ça exprès comme un canal vous
aime pas les menottes la gueule
artistiquement il fait plus grand chose
elle fait bar excusez-moi l'a pas sorti
d'album depuis des années sortie club
fait exprès c'est du marketing du pire
ça s'appelle c'est un truc classique et
moi j'en ai marre elle fait ça tout le
temps c'est honteux là elle méprisait la
moitié aux conservateurs d'avoir les 4 1
delphine aussi un l'abaya les
conservateurs et là il y avait un petit
peu brouille à ceux qui se font refaire
les lèvres
c'est un personnage public alors quand
même montré l'exemple et c'est pas la
première fois qu'elle fait quelque chose
qui indignent un peu certaines religions
et on sait qu'en ce moment la religion
en plus c'est thaçi donc l'art est assez
vaste pour qu'elles puissent faire autre
chose lors du
alors beaucoup de soin george bush mais
non merci
mais enfin ça fait des années qu'ils
artistes georges beaucoup font ce genre
de provocations madonna rappelez-vous
dans le clip like a prayer elle avait
déjà fait ça s'entend c'est là aucune
moi je moi je
on va chasser des petits pois et des
petits poule a où il y en a pas alors ce
qu'on pensait journalistes oui faut
arrêter de voir des politiques mais
aujourd'hui les signes religieux en plus
ils sont détournées pour plein de choses
pour des vêtements pour des bijoux et
ses parents ne sait pas parce que vous
portez un bijou avec une croix
catholique que vous êtes catholique
pratiquant donc rien n'a le droit de
faire ce qu'elle veut moi je pense que
c'est des hommes politiques là bas en un
mot ce que je me suis renseigné un peu
qu'ils veulent faire du buzz sur son dos
comme en france nous on a des maires de
certaines villes qui veulent faire du
buzz sur le dos des rappeurs parce qu'on
sait qu'ils sont bankable en annulant
des concerts de cette annonce est
scandaleuse
oui non c'est qu'elle a pardon c'est
qu'elle avait soutenu les agriculteurs
contre le il nous a soutenu à l'époque
avaient leur état sur berg donc le
gouvernement indien lui envie d'inviter
cette histoire pour remettre le truc
parce que ganesh le dieu le plus vénéré
en un tueur en asie au japon et tout ça
c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est donc voilà
j'ai c'est de l'intelligence et de
l'éducation
peut-être m'aider parce que là j'ai
l'âge et au coeur des trois ormes et
voilà bah merci alors oui et puis moi je
trouve que encore une fois l'histoire du
blasphème pardon mais la fois c'est
quelque chose d'un team c'est quelque
chose de privé
on n'a pas être fragilisé par du
blasphème en fait moi quand on blasphème
ma religion est bien peu importe en fait
ça ne va pas fragiliser ma foi on est au
dessus de ça